I am a guy I'm a guy I'm a guy I'm a boy
I am a guy I'm a guy and I'm a
girl say your name your occupation and
um yeah describe your like body type I
am just turned 28 um I'm a boxer and
yeah my body type I mean I'm in the gym
often I'm Josh I am 5'8 16 you're 16
yeah I'm 16 I think I'm the youngest
here for sure yeah definitely my name is
Tyler I'm 27 um I'm a fitness influencer
so I look like an action figure I guess
lovely confidence brother I'm will I'm
18 I'm currently a student at Stanford
and I'm around 5'7 pretty skinny hey
y'all I'm Ben I'm 21 I'm a student at
USC and then I work out pretty often um
and I'm 510 hi everyone Joseph here I'm
32 I'm about 5'8 57 and I am an urban
planner
that sounds like something like really
humanitarian like I feel like that's
something like a girl would do my name
is Caleb I'm 21 body type I'm not a big
guy I'm like 5'7 always wear like
platform shoes to kind of compensate for
that honestly I just wanted to get past
the first round I was kind of banking on
the fact that I heard other voices out
there being a little higher than mine
who thinks who's a who's a chick I think
the second person is a chick 110% the
first one you strike me as a chick that
with the platform shoes thing but the
second one is a chick in my opinion that
scared me because I was like I was
expecting people to just think that I'm
some chill dude super Chill Vibes no and
so I had to kind of work off of that
because he clocked me right away what is
something that only men would know okay
I want to ask this to number two then
sure number two what does it feel like
peeing with a
boner um difficult come on Yo spit it
out it's difficult difficult that's a
chick 110% I've never had a boner
unfortunately and I've never had to pee
with one so I was sitting there like
perhaps it feels really awesome and cool
to pee with a boner but then apparently
I was wrong I was also even sus of Tyler
just because he dominated the
conversation so much maybe he's just
saying too much because he wants to like
direct attention off of himself number
two what's your favorite video game M
Kingdom Hearts chick let's all end wait
I didn't know that wasn't a very manly
game but it's like when my favorites I
was like I know a lot of girls who play
that kind of game kingdom hearts and
Minecraft what's a feminine hobby you
have or a hobby that you like consider
more feminine I would say
meditation and yoga it helps me stay
focused on things like when I get
stressed out I'd say probably art I I
hear people say it could be feminine
sometimes but I don't believe that my
man on his Leonardo finy right man
right probably for me man I would just
say like I've been in a fashion like I'm
not the best looking guy so I've always
had to like cope with it for like
looking nice I like dancing I'm on the
Stanford cheer team go- card I love it I
just started this
year oh hey bro what are you doing here
before you go can you do me a solid and
smash that subscribe button now let's
get back to the
video
Joseph okay big step over there you go
I've been misgendered on the phone to my
face so many different circumstances I
was like okay this is just another
situation like that I'm so sorry for
voting him out but also I kind of had to
use him as a stepping stool to get to
the second round this portion of the
video is sponsored by better help you
know Charlene being blindfolded is kind
of nice yeah I want to try it yeah my uh
my therapist recommended that I spend
some time unplugging so we've been
working through tools to help me resist
that urge to be on my phone all the time
oh is that the therapist you found
through better help yes hey thank you so
much for the recommendation by the way
I've uh I've really started to feel like
myself again you know better help has
over 30,000 therapists in their Network
so it's easy to find a therapist that
gets you and you can choose how you want
to meet with them whether that's through
phone call video chat or like me
messaging because you're not in the mood
to talk all you have to do is fill out a
few questions and you'll be matched with
a professional therapist in most cases
within 48 Hours whether you're going
through a hard time or you want to
address a clinical mental health issue
therapy can give you some great tools to
approach life in a different way so if
you're struggling consider online
therapy with better help to get 10% off
your first month of better help click
the link in the description or visit
betterhelp.com Jubilee media thank you
to better help for supporting this
channel now let's get back to the
episode let's get back to the video you
didn't skip the ad I'm so proud of you
guys we're still
here who's going to win I want to finish
the feminine Hobbies question sure yeah
I personally write poetry uh something I
did ever since I was with my last
girlfriend just kind of I don't know
liked it since English class makes me
feel happy contextualizes where I am in
the world I actually dance too I don't
like to perceive it as feminine cuz I go
to a liberal arts school where it's kind
of popular to do that but I just started
doing it this last year it gives me a a
space to just kind of let loose I guess
cuz I'm in a frat so it's a little
awkward for me sometimes yeah what frat
are you in Delta to Delta all right y
vote that dude off chick or SL dude and
then end the game after that you didn't
get into the Fret did you you didn't get
a B you didn't get
trust me I don't need to get mad you're
mad I'm like okay Tyler Tyler please
just calm down just calm down just this
much can can people lie about their age
why do you want to lie about your age I
don't know the 16y you I vote you all
the way to the right why are you
overcompensating they put they put a lot
of people in here for variety reasons
that's why we have deep voice guy we
have gi Jo we have I guess the
16-year-old is like the Wild Card the
curveball all right I'm I mean we have
higher voiced people
yeah I have a high pitch voice but I'm
definitely a dude what are some
challenges as a guy would you guys say
just like coming out as gay that was
really hard just being accepted by other
guys sometimes was like more challenging
than being around girls I feel like
sometimes it's just really stigmatized
and I never wanted to be seen as weak
and I've definitely gotten a lot better
at it over time and people assuming me
have the worst intentions um I really
deeply care like I'm a Roman yeah I just
I know what you mean I know you I'm 21
I'm 21 hey dude I'm pretty dark people
Hey listen I I'll explain later yeah
okay but uh no it's genuinely cuz I just
like I'm a romantic guy like I really
deeply care about people it kindness
means a lot to me and I think it's kind
of sad when people assume like hey I'll
walk you home means like I want to have
sex afterwards I might just kind of want
to do the right thing and so I feel like
a lot of men make us all look bad and I
really dislike that you seem like you'd
be a good friend thank you I appreciate
that it's probably the dating scene I've
been on dating app since I turned 18 and
they're very discouraging to say the
least I don't get a lot of action from
girls and I feel like there's Endless
Options for women whereas for me it's
just always been a challenge I feel like
no guy would be saying that like we
we're not talking about why girls have
so many options I felt like that was a
little little telling on themselves like
maybe they got options like and they
trying to like push a the suspicion away
I would probably say the biggest
challenge about being a guy right now in
the society that we're in is just
probably just if you're not rich or have
like this $20 million boat or drive this
like Ferrari it's like not hard to get
chicks but like that's literally just
makes it much harder if you're not like
this 6'3 like Calvin Klein model say
that's pretty much why I'm a Tik Tok
influencer or whatever you want to call
it I'm just trying to get
rich I'd say something tough would be
like people ask me to open things a lot
of the time like my mom and I don't
really always have that strength on me I
fail a lot and that's embarrassing so I
think that's tough sometimes honestly
Men We we all have our problems and
women have their problems too but I feel
like for men it's very hard for them to
be able to reach out if they need things
I will literally do anything before I
ask for help like it's just how it is I
think what Allan said was very touching
and a very real experience that men have
to go through in this life we teach men
to perceive vulnerability as weakness
and that's just not the truth it's not
weak it makes you a human being do you
guys feel like you have someone that you
can go to for like emotional like
support and vulnerability yeah I have
have brother I have a twin sister my
dad
Caleb all right we're going to come and
get you I tried to do like ethnographic
research on dudes but at the end of the
day I'm a chick and there's only so much
lying that I can do please raise your
hand if you want to continue playing the
game all right majority wins you will
will not continue if the lights turn
green you voted the mole out and you win
if the lights turn red you didn't vote
the mole out and you lost and you won
yeah job boys y'all on me get off me
could there have been two M my God
ready three 2 one
go oh my God is there two chicks oh no
there isn't there's one chick there's
one Chi my name's Chloe I'm a Tik Tok
influencer just like you actually I just
didn't want to give it away I did
purposely make it deeper for this but I
don't think I trained well enough yo you
you give me you give me 070 Shake Vibes
I get that all the time I get that all
the time people have commented on my
voice since I was about 14 years old and
then I hopped on Tik Tok at 19 years old
and I started posting it it was the
first thing that people noticed about me
I've kind of used it to empower myself
because I think that it gives me a
unique quality I was so sure it was
going to be Joseph so it was actually
surprise we have a wide range of
personalities backgrounds there is a
lived experience to being a man there is
like a an inherent privilege that comes
with that that we didn't really address
like I feel like we kind of focused on
like the negative aspects of being a man
but we never really talked about like
male privilege that we just get that
we're born with all right open this up
open it my money my money w 3 four 5 six
this makes me feel like I'm a different
profession
gentlemen Prof almost to clean up now
honestly let me just put this in my
pocket
yeah